how many of you right now if I called on
you and I said I got a hundred thousand
dollars I'm gonna give away right now
who has their formal business plan with
them in their hands right now raise your
hand if you have it with you
raise the end if you have it with you
I'll give you a hundred thousand dollars
stand up if you have it with you stand
up if you have it with you
okay here's another question for you how
many of you guys how many guys your
business plan that you wrote for the
year you've read it or looked at it in
the last week
be honest straight up you spent a few
thousand dollars to come here so we
don't need in the last week how many
guys looked at your business plan look
around actually look don't look at me
look around
look around do you by the way some when
people used to do that with me in an
audience I still be like man he's making
me feel like [ __ ] right now it's not the
point the point is you just found an
edge here because no one's doing that
everyone's just winging it
your entire competition 90 they're all
winging it
and most likely you and I are also
winging it but the Market's wide open
today especially today